Welcome. Welcome. Welcome. Welcome. Welcome. Welcome. Welcome. Welcome. Welcome. Welcome to Smartless. Smart Less I feel like I want to get into talking to you guys I really do I miss you Sean I owe you a call I know that you face-time
欢迎。欢迎。欢迎。欢迎。欢迎。欢迎。欢迎。欢迎。欢迎。欢迎来到Smartless。Smart Less，我觉得我想和你们聊聊，真的，我很想你们。肖恩，我欠你一个电话，我知道你那天晚上跟我视频通话，但我没回拨，我刚刚才意识到这一点，我非常想念你们。我也很想你们，你们在芝加哥还好吗？哦，威廉，谢谢，是的。
me the other night and I never called you back and I'm just realizing that now and I miss you desperately I miss you guys too and are you okay in Chicago oh William thank you yes
我还好，我是说，除了每天、每晚都有警笛声响起，而且我们走廊对面的那个人养了条狗，他们总是开着门。
I'm okay I mean it's other than the sirens going off every single day every fucking night and the guy across the across the hall from us has a dog and they leave their door open
狗叫得特别大声，听起来就像在我们的公寓里一样，然后整条走廊的狗都跟着叫起来，每条狗都开始叫。你们跟他们谈过吗，或者至少在电梯里给他们甩过脸色？
and it barks so loud it sounds like it's in our apartment and then it gets all the dogs down the whole hallway going every dog starts barking have you talked to them about it or giving them a hairy eyeball
没有，你们觉得这栋楼里的人对口罩怎么看？我是说狗吗？它们是携带者，不，我是说楼里有些人不再戴口罩了。
on the elevator at least? No I don't what are you guys about masks like people in this building? On dogs? They are carriers no like some people in the building don't wear masks anymore
有些人觉得哦，强制令结束了。我想根据他们的长相来决定，比如，噢，你需要戴个口罩。你懂我的意思吗？还有别的吗？我总是忘记带饭去排练，所以我一直都很饿。
and some people are like oh the mandate's over I would like to do it based on how they look. Like, ooh, you need a mask. You know what I mean? But what else? I always forget to bring a meal to rehearsal, too. So I'm kind of hungry all the time.
我们只有20分钟的休息时间。如果我跑回家，这故事是不是很神奇？如果我跑回家……也许乌克兰的士兵想听听你的20分钟休息时间。是啊，也许他们想聊聊你的技术排练。零食不太好。等等，是啊。你接下来是不是要开始抱怨你的走位了？
We only get 20-minute breaks. So if I run home, isn't this an amazing story? If I run home... Maybe the soldiers in the Ukraine would like to hear about your 20-minute breaks. Yeah, maybe they want to talk about your tech rehearsal. Snacks aren't great. Wait, yeah. Are you going to start complaining about your blocking next?
是啊。是的。哦，谢谢你提起这个。等等，去跟导演说吧。我们不想听你抱怨戏里的走位。不，所以我只有20分钟。我不知道该做什么。我从来都不知道。
Yeah. Yes. Oh, thank you for bringing this. Wait, take it up with the director. We don't want to hear about the blocking on your play. No, so I have 20 minutes. I don't know what to do. I never have.
总之，我总是很饿。是啊。是啊。杰森？我没什么好抱怨的。我只是同情世界各地的同胞。我也是。肖恩，你昨晚一定会喜欢的。
Anyway, I'm always hungry. Yeah. Yeah. Jason? I don't have any complaints. I just feel for my fellow citizens around the world. Likewise. Sean, you would have loved it last night.
我让杰森的妻子阿曼达和他的女儿梅普尔来家里了。但不是杰森？和我的手机一起吃晚饭。不是杰森。不，因为今天是星期六。昨天是工作日。所以你5点就开始吃晚饭了，那意味着我还有两个小时的工作要做。
I had Jason's wife, Amanda, here at the house, and his daughter, Maple. But no, Jason? To have dinner with my phone. And not Jason. No, because today's Saturday. Yesterday was a work day. So you're starting dinner at 5 o'clock That means I still got two hours of work left
真是个笑话，这话出自那个自1月1日以来打了34天高尔夫球的人之口，而且顺便说一句，没有一天是在周末，因为他不被允许在周末打球，因为那是家庭时间。所以我们来谈谈工作日吧。等等，那不是个新规定吗？确实是个新规定，我对此感觉很好。
What a joke says this says the guy who Since January 1st has played 34 days of golf And none of them on the weekend by the way Because he's not allowed to play on the weekend Because that's family time So let's talk about work days Wait isn't that a new rule It is a new rule and I feel good about it
而且我还有一个新规定，这也是关于我们世界各地处于困境中的公民的。这和你的特斯拉有关吗？说吧。不。我是说，我不会每天都去打球了，好吗？哦，哇。
And I'm also a new rule is This is also something Our citizens and strife around the world Does it have to do with your Tesla? Go ahead. No. It's, I'm going to not play every day, okay? Oh, wow.
你知道英雄这个词用得很频繁，但我是说，在这种情况下。听着，我们演员，你知道，这不是，我们不是，这很容易，好吗？那些说哦，这太难了，时间太长了的人，拜托，我们能做自己喜欢的事已经很幸运了。但我告诉你一件事。当我和斯科蒂对台词时，只是为了背台词，特蕾西就像你背台词一样，就像你记台词一样。
You know the term hero gets used a lot, but I mean, in this case. Listen, we actors are, you know, it's not, we're not, it's easy, okay? And people that say, oh, it's so hard and the hours are so, please, we're so lucky to be doing what we're doing. But let me tell you something. When I run lines with Scotty, just from. to memorize lines, run lines, Tracy is like you run lines, like you memorize lines.
我对他的脾气很急，这和他没关系，但我会说，好吧，我进来然后说，哦，放松点，好吗，然后我说，但这只有四个糟糕的小时，能出什么错？他说，不，是当我走，回去，回到上一句台词。他会纠正你的每一个字、每一个音节吗？
And I have such a short temper with him and it has nothing to do with him, but I'm like, okay, so I come in and I say, oh, relax, okay, then I say, but it's only four lousy hours, what can go wrong? And he says, no, it's when I go, go back, go back to the previous line. Does he correct you on every word, every syllable?
是的。他会来排练场坐在观众席吗？你会去斯科蒂那里对台词吗？不，对于实际演出，你能想象他能不能带个腰包，里面装点零食之类的给你？我知道这是个好主意。你能给我做一个装零食的腰包吗？零食包，零食包，你知道这简直就像他在遛你，就像他是遛狗的，但他是为你服务的，他有个腰包，里面可以放些湿巾之类的。斯科蒂带着零食包，我们试着给肖恩买那个马桶，结果没用。
Yeah. And does he come to rehearsal and sit out in the audience and does he, do you go line in Scotty's, no for the actual performances did you imagine can he maybe have like a fanny pack that's got snacks in it or something for you i know that's a good idea can you make me a fanny pack with snacks a pack snack snack you know it's almost like he's walking you like he's a dog walker but for you and he's got a fanny pack and he could have some wipes and stuff it's a snacky pack scotty with a snacky pack we tried to buy sean that toilet too and then it wouldn't work
对，是啊，杰森和我本来想给你买个高级马桶，我知道那太好了。听众朋友们，当我们巡演时，当你和某人住在一起，你会了解他很多。而甜甜的肖恩，尽管他过去五分钟听起来很优越，但他完全不知道智能马桶已经悄悄流行起来了。他以前从没听说过。你知道那些托托马桶，就是会喷水柱的那种。好吧，不，我是说，人们知道它们。没多少人有。但，我是说，这就像是一种奇怪的新技术……
right yeah what jason and i wanted to buy you a fancy toilet i know that was so nice Listener, so when we were on the tour, you'd learn a lot about someone when you're living with them. And sweet, sweet Sean, as privileged as he sounds with this past five minutes, he was completely unaware that the toilets with the washlet has snuck up on him. And he'd never heard of it before. You know, those Toto toilets that, like, shoot a geyser in you. Well, no, I mean, people know about them. Not a lot of people have them. But, I mean, it's like, it's this bizarre new technology in...
这是内置在浴缸里的坐浴盆。是啊，所以我们试着买……杰森和我试着，在得知……肖恩不知道。为了他的生日。我从浴室出来。我当时很敬畏。我说，哦，天哪，有这些开关。
It's a bidet built into the bathtub. Yeah, so we tried to buy... Jason and I tried to, after learning of... Sean didn't know. For his birthday. I came out of the bathroom. I was like in awe. I was like, oh, my God, there's these switches.
它可以清洗你的屁股。然后它还能吹干你的屁股。我们住的酒店有一个，他简直不敢相信。我们当时想，得了吧，你从来没……所以我们知道，嗯，他在芝加哥。他在洛杉矶的城堡里做一些改造。所以我们试着安排这个。丈夫去装个新马桶，结果比马桶本身还贵。
It can clean your ass. I can then it blow dries your ass. We were staying in a hotel that had one, and he couldn't believe it. And we're like, come on, you never... So we know that he, well, he's away in Chicago. He's doing some remodeling in the castle there in L.A. And so we tried to arrange with this. husband to get a new toy toy put in there and it ended up being more expensive than the toilet
玩具马桶。你得把墙拆了，还得接管道什么的。但心意最重要，你们能想到这一点真是太贴心了。我本来打算给你们买保时捷的，但没成功。好吧，还有时间。还有时间。也许再试一次。心意最重要。心意最重要。说到还有时间，我们的时间不多了，因为我们有一位很棒的嘉宾，他一直很有耐心地等待，表现得非常优雅。抱歉，那是我的错。而且他，这是一个能理解演员困境的人，因为他已经在高水平的表演领域工作了比我们三个所知道的还要久。
itself. Toy toy. You had a tire down the wall and they go into the pipes and everything. But it's the thought that counts and you guys are so sweet to think of that. And I was going to get you guys Porsches, but I just didn't work out. Well, there's still time. There's still time. Maybe try again. It's the thought. It's the thought. Speaking of still time, we're running out of time because we have a great guest here who has been really biting his time waiting and being so gracious. Sorry, that's my fault. And he, this is somebody who can relate to actor problems because this is a person who's been acting at a high level for longer than the three of us have ever, you know,
甚至不知道世界上发生了什么。这是一个从舞台起步，获得巨大赞誉，进入电影界，多年来制作了无数高水平电影，有出色表演的人，不是迪克·范·戴克。不仅如此，事实证明，我们还一起主演了三部电影。一起拍电影，这只会让他显得低调，却衬托了我，让我看起来很棒。
even known what the hell was going on in the world. This is somebody who started on the stage, it's a great acclaim, moved into films, has made countless films over the year at the highest level, great performances, not Dick Van Dyke. Not only that, he and I have starred together, as it turns out, in three pictures. pictures together, which only brings him down and props me up and makes me look good.
他是我一直非常钦佩的人，因为他是一位不可思议的演员，他是《坚果行动》、《坚果行动2》、《乐高大电影》的主演。还有，也许，还有《辛德勒的名单》、《飓风营救》系列。哦，天哪。他有一部新电影要上映了，叫《记忆》。伙计们，他就是连姆·尼森先生。那才是真正的电影明星。就在那儿。
He's somebody that I've just admired for so long because he's such an incredible actor, and he's the star of The Nutjob, The Nut Job 2, the Lego movie. Also, perhaps, Schindler's List, The Taken Movies. Oh, good Lord. He's got a new film coming out in memory. You guys, it's Mr. Liam Neeson. That's a real movie star. Right there.
嗨，肖恩。哇，早上好。看看这个。我确实很喜欢听你们说话。我确实很喜欢听你们说话。就是这样。抱歉。杰森，你打高尔夫球。
Hi, Sean. Wow, good morning. Look at this. I did love listening to you. I did love listening to you. That's where. Sorry about that. Jason, you play golf.
我必须告诉你。只是因为我试图，我试图理解普通人是如何生活的。他说他为你感到难过。你听到了吗？他说他已经为你感到同情了，杰森。我知道。我很尴尬。但我这样做是为了那种精神上的折磨。
I have to tell you. Only because I'm trying to, I'm trying to understand how the common man lives his life. He's sorry for you, he said. Did you hear that? He said that he already feels pity for you, Jason. I know. I'm embarrassed. But I do it for the mental anguish of it.
对我来说，这是工作。这很难做到。我演得很逼真。总之，我还是不认为你。正如乔治·萧伯纳曾经说过的，这是一次被毁掉的好散步。没错。这是真的。
To me, it's work. It's very hard to do. I'm very believable. Anyway, I still don't think you. As George Bernard Cho once said, it's a good walk ruined. That's right. It's true.
这是工作的一部分，努力保持积极。我们已经有了第一句乔治·萧伯纳的名言。连姆，你已经让我们的档次提升了一百万倍。非常感谢你能来，伙计。这真是莫大的荣幸。我自己也感到非常荣幸，而且我非常、非常紧张。
That's part of the job, trying to stay positive. We've had our first George Bernard Shaw quote. You have already classed us up a million percent, Liam. Thank you so much for being here, man. It's such an incredible honor. I'm very honored myself, and I'm very, very fucking nervous.
别紧张。连姆，让我从这里开始，因为这是肖恩最喜欢的话题，那就是关于剧院的故事，你多年来在剧院表演有着悠久的历史。所以，肖恩，我要给你机会直接开始。
Don't be. Liam, let me start by this, because this is an area that Sean loves the most, which are stories from the theater and you have a long history of performing in the theater for many years. So, Sean, I'm going to give you the opportunity to right off the bat
问连姆一个剧院问题，你最珍视的剧院问题。好吧，现在我被推到风口浪尖了。首先，我不敢相信我在和你说话。我知道。我从没见过你。这太棒了。太酷了。
ask Liam a theater question, your most prized theater question. Well, now I'm put on the spot. First of all, I can't believe I'm talking to you. I know. I've never met you. This is so awesome. It's so cool.
我有点紧张。所以我的问题是，你最喜欢的悲剧剧院故事是什么？我在这里讲过很多我的故事了。我正在想另一个。好吧，我可以告诉你另一个，克里斯汀，我多年前和克里斯汀·肯诺恩斯演过一部戏，听众们都听腻了我讲这个，在演出结束时，我们出来谢幕，我从对面的侧台看过去，克里斯汀和我应该从舞台的两侧出来，在中间会合，走到中心一起谢幕。
And I'm nervous a little bit. So my question to you is, what is your favorite tragic theater story? I've said so many of mine on here. here i'm trying to think of another one well i can tell you another one christian i did a play with christian chenna with years ago the listeners are so sick of me talking about and at the end of the show we come up for our bows and i look over it from opposite wings and christin and i are supposed to come from opposite sides of the stage meet in the middle walk down the center and take our bow together
很复杂，我以前从没见过。所以这些就是谢幕，是吧？你知道，带我们了解一下。谢幕，对吧？好吧。你们撞到一起了吗？你们怎么避免这种情况？你们两个角色的名字是什么？《承诺与承诺》，对吧？
complicated and i never seen that before these so these are the these are the curtain calls huh You know, walk us through. The boughs, right? Okay. Did you bump into each other? How do you avoid that? What were your two characters name? Promises and promises, right?
是那两个角色吗？继续，肖恩。优雅的嘉宾。所以我看过去，克里斯汀不在那儿。我就想，哦，天哪，每个人都在鼓掌等着我们出来。我就想，克里斯汀在哪儿？我一看，她死死地晕倒了。在地板上，晕倒在地板上。
Are those the two characters? Keep going, Sean. Classy guest. So I look over and Kristen's not there. And I'm like, oh, my God, everybody's clapping waiting for us to come out. I'm like, where's Kristen? And I look over, and she's dead passed out. on the floor, passed out on the floor.
我就想，克里斯汀·肯诺恩斯到底怎么了？所以我当时想，舞台监督，我当时想，我是该出去吗？我该等她吗？发生了什么？他们正在试图再次唤醒她。所以我出去独自谢幕了。你当时在想，哇，我得到了双倍的掌声。所以然后她……
And I'm like, what the hell happened to Kristen Chenow? And so I'm like, stage manager, I'm like, do I go out? Do I wait for her? What's happened? They're trying to revive her again. So I went out and took my bow on myself. You were thinking, wow, I'm getting double the applause to me. So then she...
她怎么了？她晕倒了，因为她那天没吃饭。所以他们给了她一块糖，她就，恢复了……她演完了整场戏，然后在最后晕倒了。哦，天哪。你上次演现场剧院是什么时候？
What happened to her? She passed out because she didn't eat that day. So they gave her a candy bar and she, like, came back to... She did a whole show. and then passed out at the end. Oh, my gosh. When is the last time you did a live theater show?
哦，天哪。14年前，我演了一部塞缪尔·贝克特的短剧，叫《A. Joe》。大约持续25分钟。我一句话也没说。这就是原因之一。
Oh, my God. 14 years ago, I did a little Samuel Beckett piece called A. Joe. It lasts about 25 minutes. I don't say a word. That's one of the reasons.
我接了这份工作。雷·费因斯也在，那是林肯中心的一场贝克特作品之夜。那是最后一次。你想再演一次吗？不，我很好。缪斯女神已经离我而去了。
I took the job. And Ray Fines was, it was an evening of Beckett pieces at Lincoln Center. That was the last time. And do you want to do it again? No, I'm good. The muse has gone from me.
它完全离开了我。真的吗？是啊。而且，我以前会为此担心，因为我刚开始在剧院工作了四年，除了剧院什么都没做。演了老戏和《萨勒姆的女巫》，还有贝克特的作品。
It's left me completely. Really? Yeah. And it's, I don't, I used to worry about it because I started off in the theater for four years, just nothing but the theater. And did the old play and the crucible, and it's a Beckett piece.
然后大约三、四年前，缪斯女神就离开了我。我收到了一些邀请，但我只是，我喜欢看我的朋友们演。我喜欢……你是在说剧院的缪斯。剧院的缪斯，是的，杰森。但是，你知道，我听到人们这样评价剧院。
And then about three, three, four years ago, the muse just left me. I was offered some stuff, and it's just, I love seeing my friends do it. I love... You're talking about the muse for theater. Muse for theater, yes, Jason. But, you know, I hear people say that about theater
因为时间表确实非常有挑战性，但你拍的电影要求也很高。你不能要求一个比这更难的类型了，但你做到了。我可以理解也许五部电影里有一部，你在外面做所有的动作戏，但天哪，你必须拥有的耐力、职业道德、纪律，以及你必须保持的状态，这真是令人难以置信地钦佩。好吧，谢谢，你知道，只是一个不错的三幕剧。
because the schedule is really, really challenging, but the movies you are doing are so demanding. You cannot ask for a harder genre for you to do, and you do it. I can understand maybe one out of every five films, you're out there doing all the all the action stuff but my god the the amount of stamina that you must have and work ethic you have discipline that you have and and the shape you must be in it's so incredibly admirable well thank you just you know a nice little a nice little three-act
在街头，嗯，我是说，得了吧，你需要休息一下。是啊，也许是一些小闹剧喜剧，你知道，某种法国闹剧，你知道，一堆门砰砰作响，一堆抓屁股的戏，是啊，那些东西很难演。你知道，这是为了这个，还是给自己弄个播客，连姆。哦，天哪，得了吧，看看这多舒服，连姆。我要告诉你一件事，我51岁，快52岁了，我打了36……我们别谈年龄了。好吧，我们不谈年龄，但我告诉你，我前几天读了一个剧本，他们说，嗯，看看这个，他们发给你，他们感兴趣，我读了，第一场戏写着外景，夜晚，我说我不感兴趣，这是个真实的故事。连姆不在乎那个。是啊，我是说，确实需要很多那些。
drama down down the street um i mean come on you you need you need a break yeah i maybe some little farce comedy you know some some sort of french farce you know a bunch yeah a bunch of doors slamming bunch of grab ass yeah that stuff that stuff's hard to do you know is this to it or get yourself a podcast Liam oh god come on look how cozy this is Liam I'm gonna tell you something I'm 51 almost 52 and I plays 36 let's not talk about age well we won't talk about age but I'll tell you this I read a script the other day they said um take a look at this they send you there interested and I read it in the first scene said exterior night and I said I'm not interested that's a true story Liam doesn't care about that yeah I mean it does take a lot those
你拍的电影，看，我们都做过，你知道，这需要一个村庄，对吧？是啊，我拍戏时有个小习惯，我起床，锻炼30到35分钟，最多。就是这样，不超过那个。而且，你知道，当你做宣传活动时，说，哦，你自己做特技。我总是说，请听我说，我没有自己做特技。我根本不做那个。我自己打斗。我喜欢做那个。但特技，不，你知道，从窗户跳出来，摔倒，等等，等等，等等。所以你自己做打斗？是啊，打斗可不是什么便宜货。那，那不简单。是啊，但这就像学跳舞，杰森。你知道，你一定……但这仍然，我做过。
films you do look we've all done it we you know it's it's it takes a village right yeah I have a little routine when I'm doing one I get up I exercise for 30 35 minutes maximum that's it no more than that. And, you know, when you're doing the junkets and stuff, say, oh, you do your own stunts. And I always say, please listen to me, I do not do my own stunts. I don't do that at all. I do my own fighting. That I like to do. But stunts, no, you know, jumping out of windows and falling over to wait, wait, wait, wait. So you're doing your own fighting? Yeah, the fighting's no bargain. That's, that's not simple. Yeah, but it's like learning a dance, Jason. You know, you must have. But it's still, I did.
其实，我最后一次大的打斗是和威尔·阿奈特在《发展受阻》里。那本应该是，本应该是好笑的，因为它持续了太久，你知道，两个不知道怎么打架的白痴。他们最后只是在地板上摔跤。他们不断切回那个场景，我们还在打。所以我们不得不拍了大约，我不知道，大约15分钟。它真的把我送进了医院。我们不得不停工几周，因为我太累了。而这，这是20年前的事了。
Actually, the last big fight I did was with Will Arnett on Arrested Development. It was supposed to be, it was supposed to be funny because it lasted so long, you know, two idiots that don't really know how to fight. They just end up on the floor wrestling. And they kept cutting back to the scene and we're still throwing. So we had to shoot it over the course of like, I don't know, it was like a 15 minute. It literally put me in the hospital. We had to shut down for a few weeks because I was so exhausted. And this was, this was 20 years ago.
我很难对付。你会这么说，对吧？你很难对付，你真有一套。是啊，好吧，嗯，你现在每天打高尔夫球吗？我每天只打九个洞。我走不动18个洞，那是真的，但杰伊，我问过你关于那个，最新一季《黑钱胜地》的最后一集，那个家伙进来把你打得半死。我当时想，那是你吗？你说不，你他妈在开玩笑吗？不，我，有一段时间我确实想，哦不，如果有什么特技我想做，那会是……然后，然后一个特技协调员有一天把我拉到一边，他说，嘿，伙计，我知道你想为镜头做正确的事，而且一切，但让它成为。
I'm a lot to handle. you'd say that right you're a lot to you got a real back on you sure yeah okay um you play golf every day now i only play nine holes a day i can't walk 18 no that's true but jay i asked you about that last the last episode of the latest ozark chunk yes where the guy comes in and beats the crap out of you i'm like was that you and you're like no are you fucking kidding me no i uh i for a while there i kind of thought oh no i'm gonna i if there's some kind of a stunt i want to do it would be kind of and then and then a stunt coordinator took me aside one day and he said hey guy i know you're trying to do the right thing for camera and everything but having it be
你的脸，但你知道，你是在从这个家伙的口袋里掏钱。他当时就站在片场准备替身，他每一条都有报酬。所以如果你只是坐在那里试图当英雄，这个家伙也在努力谋生。我就想，哦，所以我很早就学到了那个教训。连姆，我相信你早就学到了，而且他会让你看起来很棒。没错，是啊。他会让你看起来很棒。是啊，除此之外。是啊。是啊。
your face but you know you're taking money out of this guy's pocket over here he was just standing on the set ready to double you and he gets paid for every take so if you just sit there and try to be a hero this guy's trying to make a living too and i was like oh so uh i learned that lesson early on Liam i'm sure you learned it way before and he's going to make you look good exactly yeah He's going to make you look good. Yeah, on top of it all. Yeah. Yeah.
所以当威尔，你们在《坚果行动》上，你们有时得找一些轻松的工作，也许只是用麦克风，最好是动画电影。但即使是在镜头前，也许是一些不错的家庭剧，你知道，剧情喜剧之类的。是啊，但我没机会杀人，你知道。你可以在中间做一个梦境序列，比如。
So when Will, it's kind of said that you guys on nut jobs up, you've got to look for some of those jobs sometimes that are nice and cushy, maybe just with a microphone, preferably like an animated film. But even if it's on camera, maybe some sort of nice domestic, you know, dramedy or something. Yeah, but I don't get to kill people, you know. You can have a dream sequence right in the middle of, like,
比如感恩节晚餐，你知道？那是真的。嗯哼。连姆，等等，你提到了我想问你的一件事，那就是，你知道，显然你一生中做了无数非常出色的工作。而且，你知道，其中最伟大的之一，当然是《辛德勒的名单》，还有雷·费因斯。
like a Thanksgiving dinner, you know? That's true. Uh-huh. Liam, wait, you touched on something I wanted to ask you about, which was, you know, obviously you've done tons and tons of such phenomenal work in your life and your career. And, you know, one of the biggest ones out of all of them was, of course, Schindler's List, and with Ray Fines.
然后多年后我在这里看《诸神之战》。直到电影结束我才想，哦，等等，那两个也都在《辛德勒的名单》里。你看你有多棒。我完全忘了你们俩还在另一部电影里合作过。所以你和雷夫有关系吗？就像，你认识他吗？
And then here I am years and years later watching Clash of the Titans. And it wasn't until the end of the movie. I was like, oh, wait, those two were in Schindler's list, too. Like, that's how great you are. I completely forgot that you both were in another movie together. And so do you have a relationship with Rafe? Like, did you know him?
你们建立了……不，雷夫，他是一个非常好、非常好的朋友。但我记得我们拍那部戏的时候，那是第一次……我们拍了两部，《诸神之战》和……《诸神之怒》，是吗？是啊。第一部是近13年前了。但当雷夫出现时，他演哈迪斯，你知道，地狱之神。
Did you build a... No, Rafe, he's a really, really good friend. But I remember when we shot that, that was the first... We did two at Clash of the Titans and... Wrath of the Titans, was it? Yeah. And the first one was nearly 13 years ago. But when Raif comes on, he's playing Hades, you know, the God of Hell.
而我是宙斯，众神之神。他来了，他是我的兄弟。我演不了那场戏。我无法直视他的眼睛。我不得不一直盯着他的额头。为什么？为什么？因为他一直让你笑场？好吧，我们只是，你知道，我们戴着假发和胡子，还有所有这些东西。
and I'm Zeus, the god of gods. He comes, and he's my brother. I couldn't do the scene. I couldn't look him straight in the eyes. I had to keep looking at his forehead. Why? Why? Because he kept cracking you up? Well, we just, you know, we're dressed in wigs and beards and all this stuff.
就像，哦，得了吧。太好了。我没法和他演那场戏。我不得不一直盯着他的额头。有些人你和他们有那种关系，你们有那种化学反应，他们只会让你笑。当我做《发展受阻》时。
And it's like, oh, come on. It was so good. I couldn't do the scene with him. I just had to keep looking at his forehead. There are people that you have that kind of relationship with, where you have that kind of chemistry that they just make you laugh. and when I was doing a rest,
是托尼·海尔，他演巴斯特，我们经常一起进入一个场景，所以我们会在我们的起始位置，我们会看到ADB看着我们，准备给我们提示。而且，就像，就在你能听到对话时，我们快要得到提示了，托尼会立刻进入他的巴斯特角色。
it was Tony Hale, who played Buster, and we would often come into a scene together, and so we'd be on our start mark, and we'd rewinn the ADB looking at us, about to give us our cue. And, like, right as you could hear the dialogue, we're about to get the cue, Tony would immediately kind of go into his character of Buster.
突然间，他会站在那里，然后他会走，抬起眉毛，是啊。噢，像这样，准备好了。一旦他那样做，我就忍不住笑。所以我进入场景时已经在笑了，因为他，我只是笑场了，你知道我的意思吗？哦，天哪，现在说到那些不专业、无法控制自己的人，劳拉·琳妮，你的朋友，嗯，天哪，我们终于演完了那部戏，你是怎么做到保持。
All of a sudden, he'd be standing there, and then he'd go, and raise his eyebrows, yeah. Ooh, like this, get ready. And as soon as he did that, I couldn't stop laughing. And so I'd come into scenes laughing already because he's, I've just corpced off, stage you know what I mean oh god now speaking of people that are unprofessional and can't keep it together laur lindy your friend um boy we finally got through that show how have you managed to stay
和那样一个多年来如此不自律、没有才华的人保持朋友关系的？我知道，我知道，嗯，过来。所以什么时候能看到第三季第二部分？我看过第一部分，我看过，我喜欢这部剧，顺便说一句，这是……哦，黑钱胜地。是的，黑钱胜地。哦，抱歉。是啊。谢谢。是的。
friends with somebody that undisciplined and untalented for so many years i know i know um come here so when am i going to see series three part two i've seen part one i've seen i love the show by this is uh ohzark yeah Ozark. Oh, sorry. Yeah. Thank you. Yes.
不，它在四月底。四月底播出，但可能就是现在。而那个劳拉，天哪，她演得好吗？是的。她，你们是很多、很多、很多年的朋友了，对吧？是啊，是啊。她有很多关于你的很棒的故事，我敢打赌你也有她的。但是，你知道，这只是一个，抱歉，听众朋友们，就一秒钟。
No, it's coming the end of April. End of April when this is going to air, but probably right about now. And that Laura, my goodness, is she good? Yes. She's, you guys have been friends for many, many, many years, right? Yeah, yeah. She's got so many great stories about you, and I'll bet you of her. But, you know, it's just a, sorry, listener, for just a second.
听众可以理解这一点。任何人在任何工作经历中，工作环境中，如果你喜欢和你一起工作的人，你永远不会觉得在工作。而她真是太不可思议了，用她的好氛围、积极性和温暖感染了整个片场。
The listener can relate to this Anybody in any working experience Work environment If you love the people that you work with You don't spend a minute working ever And she was just so incredible In sort of washing the whole set With her good vibes and positivity and warmth
你觉得她会这样评价你吗？不不不不。我们俩之间，我们达到了某种中间点。你们最初是一起工作的，你们是那样认识的吗？是啊，我正在想……是啊，我是不是完全忘了你们一起做的一件大事，还是只是社交？不，我们在百老汇演了《萨勒姆的女巫》。好吧。然后我们拍了一部叫《金赛性学博士》的电影。他是秘书。是啊，绝对。劳拉在那部戏里演我妻子。然后我们和安东尼奥·班德拉斯拍了另一部电影。
And do you think she'd say the same about you? No no no no Between the two of us we had We got to something right in the middle You guys worked together originally, is that how you met? Yeah, I'm trying to think... Yeah, am I totally forgetting a big thing
她和他有外遇。我们结婚了。她在《黑钱胜地》里也欺骗了我。我喜欢连姆还在为此生气。那只是部电影。特别是安东尼奥·班德拉斯。他太丑了。我是说，得了吧。
you guys did together, or was it just a social? No, we did the crucible on Broadway. Okay. And then we did a film called Kinsey. He was a secretary. Yeah, absolutely. And Laura was my wife and that. Then we did another film with Antonio Benderas.
这是它的标志。我不想让你尴尬，连姆，但这是一个伟大电影明星的标志，你几乎不记得你拍过多少电影，或者它们是什么。对于我们来说，作为粉丝，我们觉得，有这样一个人真是太令人兴奋了……好吧，你知道吗？
She was having an affair with him. We were married. She cheated on me in Ozark, too. I love that Liam is still angry about it. It's just a movie. Especially Antonio Banderas. He's so ugly. I mean, it's like, come on.
我不是在吹牛。就在过去那个圣诞节之前，我完成了我的第100部电影。不会吧。哇。哇。那太疯狂了。我不敢相信。我是说，托尼·霍普金斯过去常说。
It's the hallmark of it. I don't want to embarrass you, Liam, but it's a hallmark of a great movie star that you barely remember how many movies you've done or what they are. And for us, like, as sort of like fans, we're like, this is so exciting to have somebody who... Well, do you know something?
我们每次见面，都会互相拥抱。我说，托尼，最近怎么样？他说，棒极了。他说，我还没被发现。我感觉完全一样。但连姆，我不擅长数学，但如果你连续25年每年拍四部电影，那就会有100部电影。
I'm not blowing smoke up my ass here. just prior to Christmas past, I finished my 100th film. No way. Wow. Wow. That's crazy. I couldn't believe. I mean, Tony Hopkins used to say
所以，我是说，听着，你知道，作为演员拍一部电影是三个月。所以如果你拍四部，我是说，那意味着25年来每年工作12个月。不，不是真的，是啊。我是说，我开始，我的第一部小电影是1977年，杰森。是啊。
any time we see each other, give each other a hook. And I say, who's it going, Tony? And he says, great. He says, I haven't been found out yet. I feel the exact same. But Liam, I'm not great at math here, but if you did four movies a year for 25 years in a row, that would give you a hundred films.
所以小角色显然也算。哦，是啊。那是在爱尔兰，还是你拍第一部戏时住在英国？我想聊聊这个。我当时其实住在贝尔法斯特，我在那里的剧院，到处都是炸弹和装甲车，哦，这就像我，你知道，这有点，这有点像现在的乌克兰，我可以想象。是啊，嗯，我们在，我在这个叫抒情剧团的剧院，呃，我们演，呃，我们演，呃，我们一周演六个晚上。
So, I mean, to do, listening, you know, doing a film as an actor is a three-month. So if you did four, I mean, that's working 12 months a year every year for 25 years. No, not really, yeah. I mean, I started, my first little film was 1977, Jason. Yeah.
在动荡时期，那个剧院从未关闭。有几次有炸弹恐慌。哇。士兵会进来。我们不得不和观众一起走到街上。然后，好吧，警报解除，再回去。回去继续演戏。
So little parts count, obviously. Oh, yeah. Was that in Ireland, or were you living in England by the when you did your first show i wanted to get into this i was actually living on belfast i was in the theater there were bombs and armored cars going oh it was just like i'm you know it's um it's a bit it was a bit like ukraine i can imagine at the minute yeah um and we were in i was in this theater called the lyric players theater and uh we we played uh uh uh we played uh uh six nights a week.
那种经历是什么样的？因为，你知道，对我们来说，显然，你知道，我们是被宠坏的，你知道，没有经历过那种事情的家伙。但在那样的环境中演戏，一定感觉很遥远，这甚至感觉像是演艺事业吗？
During the height of the troubles, that theater never closed. A couple of times there were bomb scares. Wow. Soldiers would come in. We'd have to go out onto the street with the audience. And then, okay, all clear, go back in again. And go back and do the show.
还是感觉你，你每天日复一日地演戏，门外就有真实的威胁，你的心态是什么？好吧，我的心态是，我只是太激动了。
And what is that experience like? Because, you know, for us, obviously, you know, we're such pampered, you know, guys who have not have to experience anything like that. But to do a play in an environment like that it must feel so far apart does it even feel like show business
能演戏，是啊，还能拿到报酬。是啊，就是这么简单。而且你知道吗，我24岁时成为职业演员，你知道，基本上还是个孩子。而且，你知道，所有这些破事都在街上发生之类的。
or does it feel like you're what is your mindset doing a play day in and day out with real you know a threat out just outside the doors well my my mindset was I was just so thrilled
但我不知道。你只是，我感觉我只是，我在一个泡泡里，我自己的快乐泡泡。是啊。演这些戏。我们每四周演一部不同的戏，你知道。哇。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目。
to be acting yeah and getting paid for it yeah and it was literally as simple as that and you know what I was 24 when I turned professional and, you know, still pretty much a kid. And, you know, all this shit was happening out in the streets and stuff.
所以24岁时，谁是24岁时的连姆·尼森？你在看谁，然后想，天哪，如果我能拥有那样长久的职业生涯，保持那么久的关联度，并在那个年龄处于巅峰状态，现在我24岁，我希望到那个年龄还能做这些？好吧，那时谁是你的北极星？天哪，这是个好问题。好吧，当然我的野心，丹，会是，我是说，不是。我从来没想过电影。
But I don't know. You just, I felt I was just, I was in a bubble, my own bubble of joy. Yeah. Doing these plays. And we did a play, we did a different play every four weeks, you know. Wow. We'll be right back. And now, back to the show.
那是……真的吗？出于某种原因无法企及。但我心想，哦，能进入英国国家剧院不是很好吗？是啊。作为一名常驻演员，你知道？那大概就是顶峰了。当时国家剧院的大人物是谁？
So there at 24, who was the Liam Neeson for you at 24? Who were you looking at and going, my God, if I could have a career that lasts that long and hold that amount of relevance that long and be at the top of my game at that age, now that I'm 24, I hope to be that age and doing that? Well, who was that North Star for you at that point? God, that's a good question. Well, certainly my ambition, Dan, would have been, I mean, it wasn't. I never thought of movies at all.
是……说约翰·吉尔古德太久远了吗？所以，玛吉·史密斯，朱迪·丹奇，是啊。罗伯特·史蒂文斯，科林·布莱克利，他是我的英雄。他也是来自北爱尔兰的。是啊。
That was... Really? Un attainable for some reason. But I thought, oh, wouldn't it be great to be in Britain's National Theater? Yeah. As a regular player, you know? That was about the height of it. Who was the big shot in the national theater at that point?
但就是，是啊，就是那样。它是基于剧院的。然后我做了一个小……阿尔伯特·芬尼当时在国家剧院工作吗？不，不是……1976年，他演了《哈姆雷特》。是啊。那非常、非常好，我看了。
Was it... Does it go back too far to say John Gilgut? So, Maggie Smith, Judy Dench, yeah. Robert Stevens, Colin Blakely, who was my hero. He was from the North of... Ireland, too. Yeah.
哦，敢打赌。天哪。是啊，这看起来……我真是太幸运了，杰森。我是真心的。这只是……但你在演剧院，你说……我很高兴杰森提到了这一点，你说你从来没有任何野心。
But it was, yeah, it was that. It was based on theater. And then I did a little... Was Albert Finney doing, doing work in the National Theater at that point? No, not... In 1976, he did a Hamlet. Yeah. Which was very, very good, which I saw.
去拍电影，感觉那离你当时所在的地方太远了。当然。但后来你在贝尔法斯特拍了一部电影，你的第一部电影，然后你第一次在电影片场，你觉得，是啊，我能看出这看起来很对劲？就像，感觉舒服吗？不，我没有那种感觉。第一部电影是为一个福音派外展机构拍的，他们在贝尔法斯特拍电影，信不信由你，《天路历程》。
Oh, bet. My God. Yeah, it just seems... I've just been so lucky, Jason. I genuinely mean that. It's just been... But you're doing theater and you say... And I'm glad Jason brought that up that, and you said that you never had any ambition
约翰·班扬的《天路历程》，显然这部小电影还在非洲巡回放映之类的，你知道，为了传教之类的。哦，哇。哇。福音派宗教，我记得有个地方叫洞穴山，俯瞰贝尔法斯特市，我当时演耶稣基督。
to do movies, it felt like just probably so far away from where you were at that time. Sure. But then you do a film in Belfast, your first film, and then the first time you're on a movie set, do you think like, yeah, I could see this seems about, right? Like, did it feel comfortable? No, I didn't have that. The first movie was for an evangelical outreach who were making a film in Belfast, believe it or not, of Pilgrim's Progress.
当然。而且我其实，我被钉在十字架上。所以我被钉在十字架上，戴着假的荆棘冠，手里拿着，你知道，化妆，你知道，插着假钉子之类的。我记得当时在想。
John Bunyan's Pilgrim's Progress and apparently the little film is still touring Africa and stuff, you know, to get converts and stuff. Oh, wow. Wow. The evangelical religion and I remember there's a place called Cave Hill that sort of overlooks the city of Belfast and I was playing Jesus Christ.
为什么他们不转动摄像机？为什么他们不说开始之类的？他们都在，福音派团队，他们都在祈祷。哦，哇。我站在那里，我想，我的手臂变得好颤抖。
Sure. And I'm actually, I'm crucified. So I was on a cross with a fake crown of thorns and stuff in my hands with, you know, makeup, you know, false nails stuck in them and stuff. And I remember thinking,
我往下看着贝尔法斯特，我看到装甲车来来往往，警笛声响起之类的，我说，这他妈太疯狂了。但我喜欢它。渴望一部不错的小独幕剧。是的。
why are they not rolling the camera? Why are they not saying action and stuff? And they were all, the team of the evangelical people, they were all praying. Oh, wow. I was standing there and I was like, my arms were getting so shaky.
你当时在想，你当时在想，我终于成功了。是啊。那太搞笑了。所以然后你搬到英国，你从那时起真正开始了你的电影生涯，是吗？我是说，那是……
And I'm looking down in Belfast and I've seen armored cars going up and down and sirens going and stuff and saying, this is fucking crazy. But I love it. Yearning for a nice little one act. Yes.
不，我搬到英国。我搬到都柏林，有幸在那里演了几部戏，然后我加入了艾比剧院，那是爱尔兰，我想是爱尔兰的国家剧院。我在那里待了一段时间，我演了斯坦贝克的《人鼠之间》，约翰·博尔曼，电影导演。
And you're thinking, you're thinking, I finally made it. Yeah. That's so funny. So then you move to England and you start your film career in England really in earnest at that point, yeah? I mean, that was...
他住在爱尔兰，他来看了，他正在筹备这部电影《神剑》。哦，是啊。亚瑟王传说。他问我演什么，加文爵士。我演了这部电影。穿着闪亮的盔甲，我自己，我最好的哥们，基兰·海因兹，演兰斯洛特。
No, I moved to England. I moved down to Dublin and was fortunate enough to do a couple of plays there and then I joined the Abbey Theatre, which was Ireland, is Ireland's national theatre, I guess. I was there for a while and I did a production of Steinbecks of Misen Men and John Borman, the film director
虫子真的咬了我。我想这真是太棒了。我是说，你开始你的第一个电影角色时演的是耶稣。我是说，那之后的一切都算是一种退步。我是说，当他来找我，他说，你想演这个骑士吗？你当时想，伙计，我上一部演的是耶稣。你怎么准备试镜去演耶稣？
who lives in Ireland, he came to see it and he was putting together this film Excalibur. Oh, yeah. Arthurian legends. and he asked me what I play, Sir Gawain. And I was in this film. With the shining suits of armor, myself, my best buddy, Kieran Heinz, was Sir Lott.
我是说，在镜子里练习你的表情去演耶稣基督。我真的不知道该去哪儿。他甚至是怎么研究那个的，你知道？是啊，我不知道他怎么，我能看到那位先生的脸，安德森先生。我想是肯·安德森，他负责这个小外展机构。我没有试镜。我只是见了他。他知道我是天主教徒，爱尔兰天主教徒。
And the bug really got me down. I thought this is just the best. I mean, you started your first film role you're playing Jesus. I mean, everything after that is kind of a step down. I mean, when he comes to me, he said, do you want to play this night? you're like, guy, I was Jesus in the last one. How do you even prepare an audition to play Jesus?
我们从来没真正谈过专业问题。这次拍摄只有大约三周左右，你知道。你刚才提醒我了。我有个画面，威尔，你不是在《发展受阻》里演过耶稣基督作为你的幻觉之一吗？乔布不是有什么宗教主题的幻觉吗？我记得你穿着某种缠腰布。是啊，然后我进了洞穴，我打算回来，然后我被困在里面了。
I mean, practicing your faces in the mirror playing Jesus Christ. I would not really know where to go. How did he even research that, you know? Yeah, I don't know how he, I can see the gentleman's face, Mr. Anderson. I think it was Ken Anderson, who was in charge of this little outreach. And I didn't do an audition. I just met him. and he knew I was Catholic, Irish Catholic,
然后开始抱怨。是啊，那是一个非常，不是一个经过深思熟虑的幻觉，我的角色。你为了准备那个场景，几周里只吃李子和芜菁，对吧？他们最后找到了我，因为我，舞台上有一个假的洞穴背面，然后他们最后，他们是那些仓储设施之一，他们正在做那些虚假的，你知道，那些节目，他们去仓储设施拍卖所有东西，他们发现了这块石头。
and we never really spoke about professional questions. And this shoot was only about three weeks or something, you know. You just reminded me there. I had a vision of, Will, didn't you play Jesus Christ unarrested for one of your illusions? Didn't Job had like some sort of a religious-themed illusion? And I remember you in some sort of a loincloth. Yeah, and then I went into the cave, and I was going to come back, and then I got stuck in there.
他们发现我住在里面。哦，伙计。几个月后，我一直被困在这个箱子里。当时很瘦。然后，但是，我，所以连姆，你提到了托尼·霍普金斯和威斯康星州的特蕾西。顺便说一句，连姆，如果你不是，我不认为你是这个播客的听众。
And started whining. Yeah, it was a really, it was a very, not a very well-thought-out illusion by my character. And you ate nothing but plums and turnips for a few weeks just to prepare for that scene, right? And they ended up finding me, because I got, there was a false sort of back on the cave that I put on the stage, And then they ended up, they were one of those storage facilities, and they were doing one of those faux, you know, those shows where they go into storage facilities and they auction off all the stuff and they find this rock
是的，但特蕾西是肖恩在威斯康星州的妹妹。所以每当我们提到人们可能不知道的事情时，我们都会和特蕾西交谈并向她解释。特别是演艺圈的内幕。是啊，所以特蕾西，托尼·霍普金斯是安东尼·霍普金斯爵士。我想你们第一次合作是在《叛舰喋血记》。是这样吗？没错。
and they find me living in there. Oh, boy. Sort of months later, I've been stuck in this case. And it was very thin at the time. And then, but I, so Liam, you mentioned Tony Hopkins and for Tracy in Wisconsin. By the way, Liam, if you're not, I don't imagine you're listener of the podcast.
那是《叛舰喋血记》，我们在莫雷阿拍摄，那是一个岛，美丽的岛，就在塔希提岛旁边。而且，哦，天哪，我31岁了。所以我今年6月满70岁，所以那是很多年前的事了。首先，你看上去不可思议。请让我到70岁时也能这样。是啊，你看上去不可思议。我知道。
Yes, but Tracy is Sean's sister in Wisconsin. So anytime we mention something that people might not know, we talk to Tracy and explain to her. Specifically, the inside baseball of showbiz. Yeah, so Tracy, Tony Hopkins is Sir Anthony Hopkins. And you worked together the first time I imagine on the bounty. Is that right? That's right.
但所以你遇见，所以你在那里，你当时只拍了几部电影。我说的对吗？你拍了五六部电影？是啊，我在爱尔兰做了一些东西，在英国拍了一些迷你剧。但现在你在那里，你在塔希提岛，和托尼·霍普金斯、梅尔·吉布森在一起？托尼和梅尔，丹尼尔·戴-刘易斯。一堆伟大的英国演员。
It was the bounty, and we shot it in Morea, which is an island, beautiful island, just off Tahiti. And, oh, my God, I turned 31s. So I turned 70 and June of this year, so it's a bunch of years ago. First of all, you look incredible. Please let me be as, yeah, at 70. Yeah, you look incredible. I know.
你选角有困难，是吧？真正的困难。但你凑合着做了。拍摄那部电影的经历是什么样的？我喜欢那个。我提起它只是因为我太喜欢那部电影了。我记得年轻时看了很多遍。哦，天哪。
But so you meet, so you're there and you're, you've only made a few films at that point. Am I right? You made sort of five or six films? Yeah, I'd done some stuff in Ireland and some miniseries in England. But now you're there and you're in Tahiti with, with Tony Hopkins in Mel Gibson? Tony and Mel, Daniel Day, Lewis. A bunch of great British actors.
你们见面了，当时你才拍了几部电影，对吧？大概五六部？是的，我在爱尔兰拍过一些东西，在英国也拍过一些迷你剧。但现在你到了塔希提岛，和安东尼·霍普金斯、梅尔·吉布森在一起？还有安东尼、梅尔、丹尼尔·戴-刘易斯，以及一群优秀的英国演员。
You had trouble casting it, huh? Real trouble. But you may do. What was that experience like making it? I loved that. I bring it up just because I loved that film so much. I remember as a youth I watched it many times. Oh, gosh.
你在选角时遇到了困难，对吧？确实很难。但你还是做到了。制作那部电影的经历是怎样的？我很喜欢那部电影。我提起它只是因为我太喜欢那部电影了。我记得年轻时看过很多遍。天哪。
Yeah, it was, it was. It was good. It was six to eight weeks, and I just, we all just loved Tony because he, as well as been, you know, Captain Bly, he played brilliantly. He took care of us. He took care of his crew. And a lot of the crew were guys just fresh out of drama school in England, you know. First job, and there you are in Tahiti, you know.
是的，确实是。那段时光很美好。拍摄持续了六到八周，我们所有人都非常喜欢托尼，因为他不仅扮演了布莱船长，而且演得非常出色。他照顾我们，照顾他的船员。很多船员都是刚从英国戏剧学校毕业的小伙子，你知道的。那是他们的第一份工作，而他们当时身处塔希提岛。
But Tony just took care of us. And I never forget that quality. had. And we had a lovely, a great director, Roger Donaldson, from New Zealand. But he and Tony didn't get on terribly well because he would do endless takes. Like, I remember one day, 27 takes of hoisting the princess, the heathian princess up onto the bounty. Oh, God. Like 27 takes and the sun beating down and stuff. And what's the point of my story? It was just great. It was a great experience.
但托尼就是那样照顾我们。我永远不会忘记他那种品质。我们还有一位很棒的导演，来自新西兰的罗杰·唐纳森。但他和托尼相处得不太好，因为他总是要求没完没了地重拍。比如，我记得有一天，为了把公主，那个海地公主吊上“邦蒂号”，我们拍了27遍。天哪。拍了27遍，太阳还直射着，诸如此类。我讲这个故事的重点是什么呢？就是那段经历真的很棒。
But we all started developing that. What's the opposite of cabin fever when you're surrounded by water all the time? There's a scientific, there's a medical name for it. So if somebody sent you out a newspaper from Britain or Ireland, you would read this from cover to cover. Sure. And then someone would, you'd give it to your friend to read to, you know.
但我们所有人都开始出现那种症状。当你一直被水包围时，那种幽闭恐惧症的反义词是什么？这有个科学的、医学上的名称。所以如果有人从英国或爱尔兰给你寄来一份报纸，你会从头到尾把它读完。当然。然后你会把它给你的朋友读，你知道的。
By this stage, the newspaper is a week old. and then you'd start, I'd say, Richard, where's my paper? I said, but you read it, you finished, it doesn't matter. I want it back. So we were there for three months. So we were just all starting to get on each other's nerves. If you watch The Bounty today, do you think you would have notes for your performance? As your style of acting changed over the years,
到这个时候，报纸已经是一周前的了。然后你会开始说，理查德，我的报纸呢？我说，但你已经读过了，你读完了，没关系。我想要回来。所以我们在那里待了三个月。我们开始互相厌烦了。如果你今天看《邦蒂号》，你觉得你会对自己的表演提出意见吗？随着这些年你表演风格的改变，
that presupposes that you watch what you do. Are you one of those actors that watches what you do? Because some don't like to. No, I don't. I like to say it at least once. I mean, if I'm playing the lead, I'll watch it at least a couple of times, but that's it. This is while you're shooting, right?
这预设了你会看自己的作品。你是那种会看自己作品的演员吗？因为有些人不喜欢看。不，我不看。我喜欢至少看一次。我的意思是，如果我演主角，我会至少看几遍，但仅此而已。这是在你拍摄的时候，对吧？
You'll watch one of the playbacks to see if you're kind of on the right track. No, I don't do that, Jason. I don't. Unless it's some technical thing, where the director needs me to be in the left. And I think, no, I should be on the right of this character, for example. But you'll watch the final product, though.
你会看回放来看看自己是否走在正确的轨道上。不，我不那样做，杰森。我不看。除非是一些技术性的东西，导演需要我在左边。而我想，不，比如我应该在这个角色的右边。但你还是会看最终成品吧。
Yeah, yeah, I would watch it. So what about your style? I just say, I ask Edwards, because I'm so, I get so cringy when I look at the old stuff that I've done. And I say, oh, my God, I do it so differently today. Because you have such a wide body of work. I'd imagine it would be pretty fun or scary or what for you to look at all the stuff you've done way back when.
是的，是的，我会看。那么你的风格呢？我只是说，我问爱德华兹，因为我每次看我过去演的东西时，都会感到非常尴尬。我说，天哪，我今天演得太不一样了。因为你有如此丰富的作品集。我想回顾你很久以前做的所有事情，对你来说应该会很有趣，或者很可怕，或者是什么感觉。
Oh, God, yeah. It's overacting, isn't it? I don't know if you ever feel loud. Any time I see something, I think, oh, God. That's what I notice I try to do, is do less and less every year. Yeah, yeah. If I do something, I used to when I was younger, would watch it once, and now I don't watch anything I do.
天哪，是的。那是表演过度了，对吧？我不知道你是否会有这种感觉。每次我看到一些东西，我都会想，天哪。我注意到我每年都在尝试做的一件事，就是做得越来越少。是的，是的。如果我做某件事，我年轻时会看一遍，但现在我不看我做的任何东西。
And if somebody comes up and who says, that was really good, I'll check it out. But if nobody says that to me, I don't need to see it. Yeah, but Sean, Sean, you were on a very popular. popular comedy sitcom for many years. The Millers? Yes. Yeah, the Millers that we run together. And we, you were like in the top, you know, in the top,
如果有人走过来对我说，那部戏真的很棒，我会去看看。但如果没人跟我说，我就不需要看它。是的，但是肖恩，肖恩，你多年来一直出演一部非常受欢迎的喜剧情景剧。《米勒一家》？是的。是的，我们一起演的《米勒一家》。而且你当时处于，你知道，处于，
one of the top shows for many years, and it was, it would be hard to avoid that. I've never asked you this. So how did you avoid that? You must have seen episodes of your show when it was on the air because it was kind of everywhere. Yeah, Liam, take a seat just for a second. I would No, I would Yes, you're right
多年来最顶尖的节目之一，而且很难避开它。我从来没问过你这个问题。你是怎么避开它的？你一定在节目播出时看过你的剧集，因为它到处都是。是的，利亚姆，稍等一下。我会，不，我会，是的，你是对的。
The reruns when they used to have reruns And all this stuff And it is hard to avoid But the reboot of the Will & Grace three seasons I haven't seen one episode Just because... Really? Just like everybody else. I was there.
重播的时候，当他们过去有重播的时候，还有所有这些东西，确实很难避开。但是《威尔和格蕾丝》的重启版，三季，我一集都没看过，只是因为……真的吗？就像其他人一样。我就在那里。
Just like everyone else, I heard that. So you wouldn't have viewing parties, Sean, of your stuff, no. Maybe when I was like 27 and I was on up 20... Liam, I want to ask you something You know, because you mentioned 100 films It's just an unbelievable accomplishment. There has to be an award for that or something.
就像其他人一样，我听说了。所以你不会举办观看派对，肖恩，你的作品，不会。也许当我27岁的时候，我正在……利亚姆，我想问你一件事，你知道，因为你提到了100部电影，这真是一个令人难以置信的成就。一定有某种奖项之类的。
Or we'll make one for you and send it. And by the way, that includes, you know, narrating documentaries and stuff. Yeah, but that's... And let's not forget the one you did with my sister called Satisfaction, where she played a little rock and roll star. Wait, is that it? Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
或者我们会为你做一个并寄给你。顺便说一句，这包括，你知道，为纪录片配音之类的。是的，但那是……而且别忘了你和我妹妹一起拍的那部叫《满足》的电影，她在里面扮演一个小摇滚明星。等等，是那部吗？哦，是的。哦，是的。
She played the lead of a band, and what did you... Oh, I saw that movie. Did you play the manager, the band manager or something? No, I was a retired ex kind of... Keith Richards sort of guy. Yeah, I think they wanted me to manage them or so, you know, yeah, yeah, yeah. You did not submit that that year for Academy Consideration, did you? No.
她扮演一个乐队的主唱，你演了什么……哦，我看过那部电影。你演的是经理，乐队经理还是什么的吗？不，我是一个退休的，前那种……基思·理查兹类型的人。是的，我想他们想让我管理他们之类的，你知道，是的，是的，是的。你那年没有提交那部电影参加奥斯卡评选，对吧？没有。
No, no. Wait, Jason, I remember that film. That was your sister's kind of breakout attempt from family ties. Yeah, I remember that film. Yeah, I think Julia Roberts was in the film, too, I think. What was it, like 30 years ago? Yeah, it was a long time. I know Julia was 19.
没有，没有。等等，杰森，我记得那部电影。那是你妹妹从《成长的烦恼》中寻求突破的尝试。是的，我记得那部电影。是的，我想朱莉娅·罗伯茨也在那部电影里，我想。那是多久以前，30年前吗？是的，那是很久以前了。我知道朱莉娅当时19岁。
Wow. So that made me, I was 34. You're crazy with numbers. How do you remember 31 years old, 19 years old? He's like Will Arnette. Are you one of those people that can remember what you did, like, April of last year versus June of last year? No, no, that I can't. Will Arnett can't?
哇。那让我，我当时34岁。你对数字太敏感了。你怎么记得31岁，19岁？他就像威尔·阿奈特。你是那种能记住你去年四月和去年六月做了什么的人吗？不，不，那个我记不住。威尔·阿奈特记不住？
I can't, yeah. Names, names to you. I'm the older, again, I have real trouble with names. Even if I'm calling my sisters, I have three sisters. I get their names confused. I know, it's tough. It's tough, I know. Jason's the same with names.
我记不住，是的。名字，名字对你来说。我是那个年纪大的，再说一次，我在名字方面真的有困难。即使我给我的姐妹们打电话，我有三个姐妹。我也会把她们的名字搞混。我知道，这很难。这很难，我知道。杰森在名字方面也一样。
Well, Jason's the same with faces. I was just going to say. I think I discovered my smallest dog yesterday, who, you know, we've had for eight years now. I think he's got facial blindness, right? Whatever that thing is. He barks at me every day. And usually about 30 seconds after he just saw me last.
嗯，杰森在认人脸方面也一样。我正要说。我想我昨天发现了我的小狗，你知道，我们养了八年了。我想他有面容失认症，对吧？不管那叫什么。他每天都对我叫。通常是在他刚见到我30秒后。
And he'll look at me like I'm a stranger that's just broken in through the side window and I'm coming in to do a lot of damage. I'm like, guy, I just fed you. The actor in you wants desperately for him to recognize you. Please, I walk around with my headshot and it's signed. He doesn't want it. I watch, you always have a stack of headshots with you, which I admire.
他看着我，就像我是个刚从侧窗闯进来，准备搞破坏的陌生人。我就像，伙计，我刚喂过你。你体内的演员渴望他能认出你。拜托，我随身带着我的签名照。他不想要。我看着，你总是随身带着一叠签名照，我很佩服。
I think that takes a lot of guts. Just to try to disarm some sort of unfriendly. Yeah. But Jason, your dog's interesting. Maybe it's... That is interesting. I adore dogs. That's fascinating.
我觉得这需要很大的勇气。只是为了试图解除某种不友好的状态。是的。但杰森，你的狗很有趣。也许是……那很有趣。我喜欢狗。这太迷人了。
I do, too, but not this one. Jason, by the way, speaking of your dog, I met this guy yesterday. You know, Frank, your dog... A top dog? Your top dog I met a guy yesterday and this is a true story I forgot to tell you
我也喜欢，但不是这一只。杰森，顺便说一句，说到你的狗，我昨天遇到了这个人。你知道，弗兰克，你的狗……顶级狗？你的顶级狗，我昨天遇到了一个人，这是一个真实的故事，我忘了告诉你，
and he said my dog is Jason's dog Frank's brother and I said no kidding and he said yeah the guy who I Oh
他说我的狗是杰森的狗弗兰克的兄弟，我说不是吧，他说是的，那个人我……哦。
First of all my dog's name is Hank Nice to meet you Frank And so his dog is related to my dog Hank Now this dog's name Your dog's name is Petrol
首先，我的狗叫汉克。很高兴见到你，弗兰克。所以他的狗和我的狗汉克有亲戚关系。现在这只狗的名字，你的狗的名字叫佩特罗。
Nice chai Peter You didn't remember either Shand... Bella. Bella. Bella. So, yeah, now that's my other dog who's, he recognizes me right away.
很高兴见到你，彼得。你也没记住，肖恩……贝拉。贝拉。贝拉。所以，是的，那是我的另一只狗，他能立刻认出我。
He's very loving, very lovely. I don't have a problem with him. Yeah. Sean, we all cut you off. Sean, go, please. No, I just was interested in our guest. Favorite color, Liam. Did I guess it?
他非常可爱，非常讨人喜欢。我对他没问题。是的。肖恩，我们都打断你了。肖恩，请继续。不，我只是对我们的嘉宾感兴趣。最喜欢的颜色，利亚姆。我猜对了吗？
Did I guess it, Sean? No, now you've told us your funny theater story. What's your funny movie story? He's the worst, Liam. I'm so worried. I'm going to movie stories, but I'm surprised Sean hasn't asked this yet because I'm fascinated one of the great films of all time, Schindler's List, and how that experience came to be for you. Yeah, well, I was going to ask that, too. I know.
我猜对了吗，肖恩？不，现在你已经告诉我们你有趣的剧院故事了。你有什么有趣的电影故事吗？他是最糟糕的，利亚姆。我很担心。我要讲电影故事，但我很惊讶肖恩还没问过这个问题，因为我一直对有史以来最伟大的电影之一《辛德勒的名单》很着迷，以及那段经历对你来说是如何发生的。是的，嗯，我也正要问那个。我知道。
I know everybody wants to know it, but I don't know any stories, and one of my favorite films. Yeah. I was living out in Los Angeles at the time, and my agent suddenly this script, which was just breathtakingly. horrible and beautiful and incredibly well-written. I knew Stephen Spielberg a little bit. Was it Eric Roth or Stephen Zalian? One of the two? Steve Zalien.
我知道每个人都想知道，但我不知道什么故事，这是我最喜欢的电影之一。是的。当时我住在洛杉矶，我的经纪人突然给了我这个剧本，它简直令人惊叹地可怕、美丽，而且写得非常好。我稍微认识一点史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格。是埃里克·罗斯还是史蒂文·泽里安？其中之一？史蒂夫·泽里安。
Yeah. Thank you, Jason. Steve Zalien. And I had read for Stephen with a bunch of kids when he was casting Empire of the Sun. Oh, wow. Christian Bale's first movie, right? I guess he remembered me.
是的。谢谢你，杰森。史蒂夫·泽里安。我在史蒂文选角《太阳帝国》时，曾和一群孩子一起为他试镜。哦，哇。克里斯蒂安·贝尔的第一部电影，对吧？我想他记得我。
So I was asked to go in and meet him for Schindler's List. and I had you know because it's set in the 1940s I hired a 40 suit and I tried to keep my air short and stuff and I spent about two two and a half hours with Stephen
所以我被要求去见他，为了《辛德勒的名单》。而且我有，你知道，因为背景设定在20世纪40年代，我租了一套40年代的西装，我试着保持头发很短之类的，我和史蒂文待了大约两个到两个半小时。
and Stephen had a camera it was just he and I in a room and I prepared a couple of little speeches from the film the script and then after it was over he said thank you very much and I felt great I thought well if I don't get this I've spent two and a half, three hours,
史蒂文当时有一台摄像机，房间里只有我和他，我准备了剧本里的几段小演讲，结束后，他说非常感谢，我感觉很好，我想如果我没得到这个角色，我也花了两个半、三个小时，
but one of the great movie makers of our time. And then I went to, yeah, I went to New York after that to do a play. I had to get on the stage again. I thought you were going to say, then I went to Ed DeBevix and got a dream. So you go to New York and do a play. How long do you make you wait? Well, it was quite a few weeks.
但这是我们这个时代最伟大的电影制作人之一。然后我去了，是的，在那之后我去了纽约演一部戏。我必须再次登上舞台。我以为你要说，然后我去了Ed DeBevix餐厅吃了一顿。所以你去纽约演了一部戏。他们让你等了多久？嗯，那是好几个星期。
I was doing this play where I met my wife. The play was called Anna Christie. I met my wife and Stephen and his wife Kate and Kate's mom came to see the play and they came backstage afterwards which was very sweet with them
我当时正在演那部戏，在那里我遇到了我的妻子。那部戏叫《安娜·克里斯蒂》。我遇到了我的妻子，史蒂文和他的妻子凯特，还有凯特的妈妈来看了那部戏，他们之后去了后台，这对他们来说非常贴心。
and I opened my door and I was half undressed and stuff I said oh my God Stephen I'm sorry let me put a robe on or something and Kate's mom was quite emotional quite teary after the performance the play and I went and just gave her a hug
我打开门，我当时衣衫不整之类的，我说天哪，史蒂文，我很抱歉，让我穿件长袍什么的。凯特的妈妈在演出后非常激动，眼含泪水，我走过去给了她一个拥抱。
apparently on the way when they were left and they were driving back home Kate said to Stephen that's just what Schindler would have done now Stephen told me no it was your audition
显然在他们离开回家的路上，凯特对史蒂文说，那正是辛德勒会做的事。现在史蒂文告诉我，不，是你的试镜让你得到了这个角色，但我喜欢这个故事，你知道，那就是辛德勒会做的事，就像《双虎屠龙》里那句伟大的名言，当传说
that got you the part but I like the story of you know that's what Schindler would have done like what's the great quote from the man who shot Liberty Valance when the legend
变成事实，就印传说。我喜欢认为是因为我拥抱了凯特的妈妈才让我得到了这个角色。那太棒了。现在，来自我们赞助商的一句话。
becomes fact print the legend I like to think it's because I heard Kate's mom that got me to part That's great And now A word from our sponsor
现在回到节目。与你合作过，你合作过这么多伟大的导演。你能想起他们中任何人的什么事吗？我想斯皮尔伯格应该就在顶端。那真的让你屏住呼吸。
And now back to the show Working with You've worked with so many Great directors Can you remember anything From any of them I imagine Spielberg would be right near the top of it That really kind of took your breath away
就像，啊，这就是伟大导演与优秀导演的区别。关于他或你合作过的其他任何不可思议的导演所做的事情，有什么特别引人注目的吗？他们让片场舒适的能力，他们与剧组合作的方式，
Like ah That is the difference in great directing versus good directing. Is there anything that was super noticeable about what he or any of the other incredible directors you've worked with have done, their ability to make a set comfortable, the way in which they work with the crew,
有什么突出的地方吗，也许甚至特别关于史蒂文和那部电影？因为它做得太精致了。史蒂文的情况很有趣，因为这是他第一部没有使用分镜表的电影。通常他总是使用分镜表，你可以走过去看画出来的你要拍摄的卡通图。
anything that stands out, maybe even specifically about Stephen with that film? Because it was just so finely done. It was interesting with Stephen because it was the first film he had done without using a storyboard. Normally he always uses a storyboard and you can go up and see the cartoons drawn of what you're going to shoot.
他没有，他在讲述他的人民的故事。他的犹太人民，他非常紧张。他感受到了他所讲述的故事的责任。是的，我记得我们在这里纽约演完戏的第一个周日，周日下午。
He didn't and he was telling the story of his people. His Jewish people and he was incredibly nervous. He felt the responsibility of the story he was telling you. Yeah, and I remember the first day we finished the play here in New York on Sunday, Sunday afternoon.
我周一飞走了。据我的记忆，据我所知，那是周二早上或周三早上，大约早上5点30分。我们在奥斯威辛集中营的大门口，波兰真正的奥斯威辛。我想世界犹太人大会，我想那是正确的名字，没有给史蒂文在奥斯威辛内部拍摄的许可。
I flew out on Monday. And as far as my memory, as far as I can remember, it was either Tuesday morning or the Wednesday morning, like 5.30 in the morning. We were at the gates of Auschwitz, the real Auschwitz in Poland. And I think the World Jewish Congress, I think that's the right name, didn't give Stephen permission to shoot inside Auschwitz.
但制作设计团队做得非常出色。我们在奥斯威辛外面拍摄，但让它看起来好像是在奥斯威辛内部。对。我记得那个故事。我穿着一件大皮草大衣和帽子，很暖和，尽管当时冷得不可思议。
But the production design team did a brilliant job. We shot outside of Auschwitz, but made it seem as if it was in. inside Auschwitz. Right. I remember that story. And I was dressed in a big fur coat and hat and nice and warm, even though it was unbelievably cold.
这列火车开进来了，所有这些临时演员都作为犹太人走出来，还有带着警犬的德国临时演员。这太可怕了。这太可怕了。我记得我在等我的戏份。我走在铁丝网栅栏边，看着那些犹太人在多年前被挤进去的小屋里面。我只是在看，布兰科·卢斯蒂格，他是制片人之一，他现在去世了，
And this train was coming in and all these extras were coming out as Jewish people and German extras with guard dogs. And it was terrifying. It was terrifying. And I remember I was waiting to do my bid. I walked down, you know, by the barbed wire fences and looking inside of the huts that, you know, the Jewish people were crammed into all those years ago. And I was just looking and Branko Lustig, who was one of the producers, he's dead now,
上帝保佑他，但他走到我身边说，你感觉如何？我说，是的，我很好，布兰科，你知道，我足够暖和，只是期待着开始，你知道。我们看着那些小屋，他指着一个小屋说，看到那个了吗，左边第三个，我现在是编的，但他说了，那就是我待过的地方。
God rest of him, but he came up to me and said, how do you feel? I said, yeah, I'm okay, Branco, you know, I'm warm enough and just looking forward to starting, you know. and we were looking at the huts and he pointed out to a hut and said, see that one there, third one from the left, I'm making this up now, but he said, that's where I was.
不会吧。在六岁的时候。嗯，我崩溃了。哇。是的。我崩溃了。我的膝盖开始颤抖。我想，
No way. At the age of six. Well, I just lost it. Wow. Yeah. I lost it. My knee started to shake. And I thought,
该死，这不是表演。这不是一部该死的电影。这是历史的一部分，我们在这里讲述。而我不配。我只是不停地对自己说，我不配。我是一个该死的爱尔兰演员。我应该回到
fuck, this isn't acting. This isn't a fucking movie. This is a piece of history, we're telling here. And I'm not. worthy. I just kept saying to myself, I'm not fucking worthy. I'm a fucking Irish actor. I should go back
爱尔兰去演戏。我在这里干什么？打扮得漂漂亮亮，穿着一件大皮草大衣，在这里拯救这些犹太人。这只是，这太可怕了。但史蒂文很棒。
to Ireland and go into the theater. What the fuck am I doing here? Dressed up and there's a big fur coat and here to save these Jewish people. It's just, it was terrifying. But Stephen was great.
有一个小场景，我把这些女孩中的一个，很多犹太女孩拉起来。因为这些囚犯本不应该被送到奥斯威辛，他们应该在我的工厂工作，因为奥斯卡·辛德勒有这个军火工厂，他在那里是为了拯救他们的生命，否则他们会在奥斯威辛死去。
And it's a little scene where I pull one of these girls with a lot of Jewish girls up. because these prisoners shouldn't have been sent to Auschwitz they're supposed to be working in my factory because Oscar Schindler had this armaments factory and he was there to save their lives otherwise they were going to die in Auschwitz
所以我走到这个警卫面前说，你怎么敢这样做，这些人是我的人民，他们必须回去，我在颤抖，我把一个小女孩拉起来，我做得太温柔了，因为她很冷，这个小女演员，史蒂文
so I go up to this guard and say how dare you do this these are my people they have to go back and I'm shaking and I pulled a little girl up and I was doing it too gently because she was freezing this little actress and Stevens
走过来对我说，你必须听着，停止那种客气，抓住她，把她拉起来，她的生命危在旦夕，你知道。所以我不得不
came over to me and said you've got to just listen stop the niceness grab her pull her up her life's at stake here you know so I had to
我向她道歉，我说看，我要相当粗鲁地抓住你，把你拉起来，这样这个警卫能看到你。她只有大约
I apologize her I said look I'm going to grab you quite roughly and pull you up so that this guard sees you she was only about
七八岁，我应该对警卫说，我需要这个小女孩，小手，这样他们可以清理金属外壳的内部，用于军火，但我从来没能把那句台词说对。你当时在说德语，对吧？应该是，是的，是的，但用英语，总之，我在胡言乱语，杰森，我喜欢这个。
seven or eight years of age and I'm supposed to say to the guard I need this little girl little small hands so they can clean the inside
所有的导演都不同，你知道，他们都，听着，我有一个，你刚才提醒了我，我第一次看那部电影的时候，因为我看过好几次，像很多人一样，听到你谈论它，我无法想象那种感觉，而且那种你在那一刻感受到的责任感表现了出来。
of metal casings for the armaments but I could never quite say the line right you're speaking in German at this point right supposed to be yeah yeah but in English but anyway I'm rambling Jason I love this
我记得我在剧院，老切尔西剧院，我不认为它现在还叫那个名字，但在23街和第八大道，我住在纽约。哦，是的。是的，我记得，我看了那部电影，有那一刻，每个人从火车上下来之类的混乱，每个人都吓坏了，
all the directors are different you know they're all listen I have such a you just reminded me the first time I saw that film because I've seen it a few times like a lot of people and so incredibly moving hearing you talk about I can't imagine feeling that and it comes across that sense a responsibility that you felt in that moment.
没人知道发生了什么。就在那一刻，在剧院里，火警响了。所以他们有那些闪烁的小灯。有声音在响，闪烁着，几乎就像它发生的那样，它是电影的一部分，
And I remember I was at the theater, the old Chelsea theater is, I don't think it's called that anymore, but on 23rd at 8th Avenue, I was living in New York. Oh, yes. Yeah, and I remember, I was seen that film, and there was that moment where there was the chaos of everybody coming off the train and stuff, and everybody's freaking out,
人们开始在剧院里惊慌失措，人们公开哭泣，因为它只是加剧了一个本来就已经非常紧张的时刻，它让每个人，它永远改变了那种方式，这真是一件非常发自内心的事，在那个时刻真正发生了，
nobody knows what's going on. And at that very moment, in the theater itself, the fire alarm went off. So they've got those little lights that are blinking. And there's a sound going, and the blinking and it was almost like it happened that it was part of the film
而且……是的。是的。你除了通常做的那些非常非常辛苦的工作之外，还会做什么？是的，你还在练拳击吗？那是你训练的一部分吗？我有一个沙袋。嗯，我有一个健身房，我有时会用沙袋，但我只是喜欢阅读。
and people started freaking out in the theater and people were openly weeping because it just heightened an already very heightened moment and it made everybody and it forever changed the way it was just such a visceral thing to actually have happened in that moment
我的意思是，我有一个阅读器，你知道吗？真的吗？是的。哇，你们，我们非常相似，利亚姆。轻松点，嗯。不，利亚姆和我非常相似。我喜欢阅读，而且我门外也有一个沙袋。杰森有一个沙袋，但他把它放在
and... Yes. Yeah. What do you What do you get into that is not really, really hard work like you usually do? Yeah, are you still boxing, too? Is that part of your regiment? I have a bag. Well, I have a gym, and I use a bag sometimes, but I just like to read.
厕所里，他只是进去待几分钟，或者他和他的好莱坞朋友玩传沙袋，但别用太多。是的，我得熬过这一夜。是的，嗯，我想问这个问题，你涉足过什么毒品？
I mean, I have a reader, you know? Really? Yeah. Wow, you guys are, we're very similar, Liam. Easy, well. No, Liam and I are very similar. I like to read, and I also have a bag right out the door here. And Jason has a bag, but he keeps it.
因为事情是这样的，当你，事情是这样的，他是我们的秘密武器，利亚姆，他是最好的，继续，抱歉肖恩，不，请继续，当你像你说的那样，哦，做了一百件事，像100部电影，不管是什么纪录片和所有东西，而且你在旅行，时差，夜戏和那些东西，当你年轻的时候，你就像，我该怎么熬过这个？你一定参与过什么东西来熬过
in the toilet and he just goes in there for a couple minutes at a tuck or he plays past the bag with one of his Hollywood friends but don't use too much of it yeah I gotta get through the night yeah um I would like to ask this question what drugs have you dabbled in
所有那些漫长的拍摄月份，你是在辛迪·亚当斯吗？发生了什么？你想让他承认吸毒吗？我会和你谈谈我们吸过的毒品，我吸过，我吸过蘑菇，告诉罗娜·巴雷特你最后一次参与某种非法毒品使用是什么时候。如果你不想回答，就别回答。好吧，我敢打赌，我敢打赌，我敢打赌，你现在保持清醒和活泼的方式是所有的锻炼。我敢打赌你吃得很好。听起来你保持得很好，
because here's the thing when you here's the thing he's our secret weapon Liam he's the best keep going sorry Sean no please when you're doing like you said oh a hundred things like 100 films whatever docs and everything and you're traveling and the time changes the night shoots and the stuff when you were younger you're like how am i going to get through this you had to have like partaken into something to get
读了很多书。听起来你没做很多让自己慢下来或伤害自己的事情，对吧？不，那有点。这很无聊。我的意思是，我确实，我飞钓。只要有机会，我就喜欢做那个。我们应该让你和吉米·坎摩尔联系一下。
through all of those many many films of just endless months of shooting are you Cindy adams what is going on you want him to admit to drug use i'll talk to you about the we've talked about the drugs we took i took i took mushroom tell rona barrett what the last time you participated in uh in some sort of illicit drug use you don't answer that if you don't want okay i'll bet i'll bet uh i'll bet i'll bet the way you stay up and peppy nowadays is all that exercise. I'll bet you eat well. Sounds like you're staying nice and same
吉米·坎摩尔。他很喜欢飞钓。吉米是，是的。我今年某个时候要去吉米的旅馆。我不知道什么时候。我本应该去年去的。我们有一大群人几个月后要去，我们要给你发邀请，来吧，我们今年夏天要去。
with lots of reading. It doesn't sound like you're doing a lot of things to slow yourself down or hurt yourself, huh? No, that's a bit. It's very boring. I mean, I do, I fly fish. I love to do that whenever I get a chance. We should hook you up with Jimmy Kimmel.
然后你可以教我，你是认真的吗？是的，对上帝发誓，是的。它看起来很壮观，太迷人了。他真的做得很好。哦，那太棒了，我等不及了。等等，肖恩，你还是想知道利亚姆的吸毒情况，对吧？不，不，哦，是的，抱歉，抱歉，肖恩，不，不，你不必回答他那些垃圾问题。利亚姆，很有趣，你只是，不，这很公平，我不是20岁，我只是，嗯，当然，当我在爱尔兰演戏时，演出结束后我们会去当地的酒吧，你知道，我崇拜吉尼斯黑啤酒，绝对崇拜它。是的。
Jimmy Kimmel. He likes to fly fish a lot. Jimmy is, yes. I'm going to go to Jimmy's lodge sometime this year. I don't know when. I was supposed to go last year. There's a big group of us going in a few months we're going to send you the invite come on up we're going to go this summer
然后你到了某个年纪，它就会粘在你身上。你知道我的意思吗？你开始发胖，就像，哦，天哪。我改喝红酒了。我绝对崇拜那个。是的。那增加的体重较少，但宿醉没那么有趣。对吧？
then you can teach me are you really yeah swear to god yeah it looks spectacular it's stunning it's he's really done a great job with it oh that's terrific i can't wait wait shan you still want to know about liam's drug use right no no oh yeah sorry sorry sean no no no you don't have to answer his garbage questions Liam interesting you just no it's fair enough and i'm not 20 for i i just uh And certainly when I was in Ireland in the theater, after shows we'd go to the local pub, you know, and I adored Guinness, absolutely adored it. Yeah.
是的。是的。所有的糖分？我停止喝酒八年了。是的，就在八年多前。哇，我必须说我不怀念它。我也是，杰森。
And then you turn a certain age and it sticks to you. Do you know what I mean? You start putting on weight and it's like, oh, my God. And I switched to red wine. I absolutely adored that. Yeah. That puts on less weight, but the hangovers not as fun. Right?
我们不，我们不喝酒。我不喝酒，我不喝酒，基本上是出于虚荣心。我可以承认这一点。但没关系。我们所有人剩下的恶习是什么？
Yeah. Yeah. All that sugar? I stopped drinking eight. Yeah, just over eight years ago Wow I must say I don't miss it Same here Chase it
我的意思是，这很可悲。对我来说，是的，就像糖，还有像脆脆的咸味零食，你知道，杰伊。是的，哦，高尔夫。
We don't we don't drink I don't drink I don't drink basically out of vanity I can admit that But that's okay What's the remaining vices For all of us
没有大麻软糖。哦，是的，是的。是的，嗯，我的意思是，那是一个恶习吗？我不知道。现在合法了，对吧？你试过那些吗，利亚姆？你试过含THC的软糖吗？
I mean it's pathetic With me it's yeah It's like sugar And like crunchy salty snacks And you know Jay Yeah Oh Golf
还有CBD？不，我吃含CBD和一点褪黑素的软糖。我每天晚上都吃那些。是的，让你直接睡着。我确实有睡眠困难。杰森还有其他东西给你，第一个是免费的。第一个是免费的。我之后会留下来。
No pot gummies Oh yeah yeah Yeah Well, I mean, is that a vice? I don't know. It's legal nowadays, right? Have you tried those, Liam? Have you tried the gummies with the THC in it?
让我拿你的邮政信箱之类的。人们还在用邮政信箱吗？当然，你喜欢大麻。你喜欢偶尔抽大麻。嗯，我已经好几年没抽了。我不能再抽了，但我确实吃软糖。软糖也是。你不介意那个。
And the CBD? No, I have gummies with the CBD on a little bit of melatonin. I take those every night. Yeah, puts you right out. I do have trouble sleeping. Jason's got some other stuff for you, and the first one's free. First one's free. I'm just going to stay on afterwards.
然后你还有什么恶习？你喜欢，你不喝咖啡。你喝咖啡吗？利亚姆，你是咖啡爱好者吗？不，我放弃了咖啡因。我知道。这太该死了，太无聊了。不，你非常有纪律。
Let me get your PO box or something. People still use PO boxes? Sure, you like weed. You like to smoke weed every once in a while. Well, I haven't smoked any years. I can't smoke it anymore, but I do eat the gums. The gummies as well. You don't mind that.
而且我一直在，这是一个杯子。那是什么？好吧，这是一个斯坦利杯。我崇拜它们。它能让我的黑色无咖啡因茶保持热度五、五或六个小时。哦。而且它也是我的小安全毯。
And then what's your other advice? You like, you don't drink coffee. Do you drink coffee? Liam, are you a coffee guy? No, I give up caffeine. I know. It's so fucking boring. No, you're very disciplined.
当然。我把它带到片场。我试着把它放进每一部电影里。哦，你真的吗？你试着把它放进去。你有没有用它砸过人的脸，因为你在这些……《诸神之战》？
And I'm constantly, this, it's a mug. What is that? Okay, it's a Stanley mug. I adore them. It keeps my black decaf tea hot for five. five or six hours. Oh. And it's also my little security blanket.
那会发生的。那会发生的。你现在在做任何让你尴尬的事情吗？你在看什么烂电视吗？你说你读了很多书。你在读一本你不愿意向任何人透露的漫画书吗？不。
Sure. I take it on set. I try and get it into every movie. Oh, you do? You try to get in. Do you ever smash guys in the face with it because you're in these... Clash of the Titans?
犯罪。我仍然沉迷于我的北欧黑色犯罪小说。哦，不，威尔来了。像内斯博和那些家伙？是的，内斯博很棒。亨宁·曼凯尔，他在大约四年前去世了。他简直太非凡了。我刚在我的最后一部电影里扮演了菲利普·马洛。
That's going to happen. That is going to happen. Are you doing anything currently that you're embarrassed of? Any crappy TV you're watching? You say you read a lot. Are you reading a comic book that you're not proud to reveal to anybody? No.
所以我从来没读过，我很惭愧，雷蒙德·钱德勒之前。所以我读了他大部分的作品作为准备，我想。威尔遇到了对手，这个播客里声音最沙哑的人。天哪。你们做配音工作吗？我们一起拍了三部电影。应该永远……
Crime. I'm still into my Nordic noir crime. Oh, no, here comes Will. Like, Nesbo and those guys? Yeah, Nesbo's good. Henning Mankell, he passed away about four years ago. He was just extraordinary. And I just played Philip Marlowe in my last film.
还有另一个……我们从来没见过面。而且，我们之前谈到了雷·费因斯。他也出演了《乐高蝙蝠侠》，为我的蝙蝠侠扮演阿尔弗雷德。我们有很多对手戏。哦，我不知道。是的，我们还没见过面。
So I had never read, much to my shame, Raymond Chandler before. So I read most of his stuff for preparation, I guess. Will has met his match with the smokiest voice on this podcast. Jesus. Do you guys do any voiceover work? We've done three films together. It should be never...
我真是个粉丝。我等不及了。他太棒了。利亚姆，除了偶尔的动画，你做配音工作吗？你是……电视上任何特定产品的声音吗？你做过任何商业广告吗？
And the other... And we've never met. And also, we were talking before about Ray Fines. He also was in Lego Batman and played Alfred to my Batman. And we had a lot of scenes together. Oh, I didn't know that. Yeah, and we have yet to meet.
不，因为威尔一直在谈论GMC卡车，幸运的是，他还在做。我不做。我喜欢做纪录片，我做过不少。但产品，不。你应该，天哪。利亚姆，你会赚翻的。你做过肯·伯恩斯的纪录片吗？
And I'm just such a fan. I can't wait. He's terrific. Liam, do you do any voiceover work other than the animation every once in a while? Are you the voice of... any particular product on television? You do any commercial stuff?
是的，我做过，实际上。在封锁期间，我做了，哦，有一部关于安妮·弗兰克的纪录片要出来了。哦，那很酷。我扮演了安妮·弗兰克的父亲，只有几句台词。而目前关于本杰明·富兰克林的纪录片，我想已经出来了。我有一个小角色。那部出来了吗，还是没有？
No, because Will talks about GMC trucks all the time and lucky for them, he's still doing it. I don't. I like doing documentaries, and I've done quite a few of those. But products, no. You should, my God. Liam, you would clean up. Have you done any of the Ken Burns documentaries?
还没。肯·伯恩斯是个天才。是的，他上过节目。他是一位不可思议的嘉宾。我们请过他。我们请过他。你们请过？是的，是的，是的。
Yes, I have, actually. During lockdown, I did, Oh, there's one on Anne Frank that's coming out. Oh, that's cool. I played Anne Frank's father, just a few lines. And the current one on Benjamin Franklin, I think, has come out. I have a small part. Is that one out yet or no?
而且他博学多才。他只是……你看过《阿里》吗？《阿里》？我还没看过那部。我必须说，穆罕默德·阿里是，曾经是，永远是我的偶像，一直都是。是的，那部纪录片太不可思议了。他做的关于二战的那部也太不可思议了，叫《战争》。
Not yet. Ken Burns is a genius. Yeah, he's been on the show. He was incredible guests. We had him on. We had him on. You did? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
二战，但美国内战，我至少每年看一次。太不可思议了。它出来，我不知道，25年前还是什么的。嗯，我喜欢你喜欢穆罕默德·阿里，因为你曾经，我之前提到过，你确实练过拳击，业余拳击手，练了几年？是的，我九岁开始。我想我最后一场比赛是在我17岁左右的时候。
And he's so erudite. And he's just... Did you see the Ali? The Ali? I haven't seen that one yet. I have to say, and Muhammad Ali was, is, always will be my idol, always was. Yeah, that documentary is incredible. The one he did on World War II is incredible, too, called The War.
哇，天哪，那已经大到会受伤了。是的，我开始受伤了。是的，因为孩子们总是互相打拳，但当你成为青少年，如果你要进入那个领域，你必须真的非常生气，因为你会受伤。所以你是在年轻成年或成年时练拳击，对吧？嗯，在13、14岁的时候，我开始猛长。我的意思是，我身高6英尺4英寸。
World War II, but the American Civil War, I have towards that at least once a year. It's incredible. And it came out, I don't know, 25 years ago or something. Well, I love that you love Muhammad Ali, because you were, and I mentioned before, You did box a little bit, amateur boxer for a couple of years there? Yeah, I started when I was nine. I think I had my last fight when I was like 17 or something.
那太惊人了。然后我想大约是6英尺3英寸还是什么的。拳头开始，是的，开始疼了，你知道。我记得有一次，我们在爱尔兰家乡的小教区大厅里举行了一场比赛。我和这个家伙打拳。我实际上赢了那场比赛，但我感觉我的心……我没赢那场比赛。但当我走出拳击台时，
Wow, my God, that's old enough to get hurt. Yeah, I was starting to hurt. Yeah, because like kids punch each other all the time, but then you become a teenager and you've got to really be pissed off if you're going to get into that because you can get hurt. So you were boxing as a young adult or adult, right? Well, at the age of 13, 14, I started to shoot up. I mean, I'm 6'4.
我的教练说，好吧，利亚姆，下楼去把衣服穿上。我当时……还有整理一下你的脸。但我不知道他是什么意思。衣服。哦，不。
That's amazing. Then I guess it was about 6'3 or something. And the punches were, yeah, they were starting to hurt, you know. And I remember once coming, we had a tournament in our little local parochial hall in my hometown back in Ireland. And I was boxing this guy. And I actually won the fight, but I felt my heart of arts. I didn't win that fight. But when I came out of the ring,
下去。这很奇怪。那就像一种奇怪的脑震荡，你知道。所以那是我的最后一场比赛。我知道得足够多，觉得，去他的。我要退出这个。你知道，我做了。
my trainer said, okay, Liam, go on downstairs and put your clothes on. And I was... And fix your face. But I didn't know what he meant. Clothes. Oh, no.
我做了一个我们朋友的节目，丽莎·库卓制作的，叫《你以为你是谁？》。它追踪你的祖先。她在拍摄过程中狠狠地打了你的脸吗？还有我所有的祖先，你知道，来自爱尔兰，我也是爱尔兰人。我们去了爱尔兰。每个人都是酒鬼和暴徒。每个人都打架，只是和每个人打架。有一句很棒的名言。
Go down. It was weird. And that was like a kind of a strange concussion, you know. So that was my last fight. I knew enough to think, fuck this. I'm getting out of this. You know, I did.
谢谢，肖恩。不，我的祖先。谢谢，我的祖先。哦，你的祖先。不是全国每个人。不，不是每个爱尔兰人。但我所有的祖先都是暴徒和酒鬼。这就像，为什么每个人，我不知道，
I did a friend of ours, Lisa Kudrow, produced this show called Who Do You Think You Are? And it traces your ancestry. Did she hit you hard in the face during the shooting of that? And all of my ancestors, you know, from Ireland, I'm Irish as well. And we went over to Ireland. Everybody is a drunk and a thug. Everybody fought and just fights everybody. There's a great quote.
每个人似乎都，喜欢打架。他们来自哪里，肖恩？你的家人来自哪里？丁格尔和……哦，丁格尔，美丽。凯里郡，是的，到处都是。你回去过那里吗，肖恩？只是为了我做的那个节目。
Thanks, Sean. No, of my ancestors. Thanks, of my ancestors. Oh, your ancestors. Not everyone in the country. No, not everybody Irish. But all my answers were just thugs and drunk. And it's like, why is everybody, I don't know,
只是打架。那里很漂亮，对吧？哦，太不可思议了。我想它就像……哦，丁格尔，丁格尔非常非常特别。我祖父来自丁格尔，他曾经是……他们那里有美丽的果实，丁格尔浆果。你试过吗？
everybody just seems to be, loves to be in fights. Where are they from, Sean? Where do your family hate? Dingle and... Oh, Dingle, beautiful. County Carey and, yeah, all around. You ever go back there, Sean? Just for the show I did.
不，威尔。我在想别的事情。你是。利亚姆，我们占用了你太多时间了。我们可以和你聊到永远。你真是个迷人的人，而且是那种，真是个伟大的表演者，我被你的才华所折服。
Just a fight. It's so pretty over there, right? Oh, it's unbelievable. I think it's like the... Oh, Dingle, Dingle's very, very special. My grandfather's from Dingle and he was... They have beautiful fruit from there, the dingleberries. Have you tried?
哦，闭嘴，闭嘴。谢谢你这么说，约翰。那是真的。你也是一个如此善良、善良的人。所以谢谢你在你的休息日花时间陪我们。谢谢你，利亚姆。杰森，我可以对你说，
No, Will. I'm thinking of something else. You are. Liam, we've taken way too much of your time. We could talk to you forever. You're just such a fascinating guy, and one of those, just such a great performer, and I'm just in awe of your talent.
我知道我几年前，三年前，什么的，在花园见到你时对你说过。请代我向你的母亲维多利亚问好。现在他在炫耀。这家伙是世界上最善良的人。他有一次在泛美航空的航班上遇到我母亲。
Oh, shut up, shut up. Thank you for saying, John. That was true. I'm such a kind, kind man, too. So thank you for spending some time with us on your off day here. Thank you, Liam. Jason, can I say to you,
她是泛美航空的空姐。是的。20年后，他遇到了我。他以前从没见过我，但我猜她曾经提到过她遇到过他，我是她的儿子。所以这是20年后。我们在麦迪逊广场花园看游骑兵队的比赛。
I know I said this to you before when I saw you at the garden a couple of years ago, three years ago, something. Please give Victoria your mom my love. Now he's showing off. This guy is the nicest guy in the world. He meets my mother one time on a Pan Am flight.
我看到了利亚姆·尼森。我就像，哦，天哪。我完全忘了我母亲提到过她遇到过他。他拦住我。他说，嘿，嘿，你是杰森·麦克。我多年前在飞机上遇到过你母亲。她怎么样？她还在做……记得她的名字？
She was a stewardess for a flight attendant for Pan Amp. Yeah. 20 years later, he runs into me. He's never met me before but I guess she had mentioned once she had met him that I was her son. So this is 20 years later. We're back at a ranger game at Madison Square Garden.
这让我震惊。然后当我告诉我母亲这件事时，她哭了一个星期。我的意思是，是的。所以非常感谢你成为这样一个善良的人。哦，拜托。还有贾斯汀，也请，请代我向他们问好。我会告诉她的，肯定的。
And I see Liam Neeson. I'm like, oh, my God. I'd totally forgotten that my mother had said anything that she'd met him. He stops me. He says, hey, hey, you're Jason McI. I met your mother X number of years ago on a plane. How is she? Is she doing it remembered her name?
而且这是一件事，我不太记得杰森，但那是一次从洛杉矶到伦敦的航班，泛美航空，当然已经不存在了，或者从伦敦到洛杉矶，我不记得了。我当时非常脆弱，不是因为我有飞行恐惧症，我没有。发生了什么事，出于某种原因，维多利亚，你母亲在我身上发现了什么，
It just knocked me out. And then when I told my mother that, she cried for a week. I mean, yeah. So thank you so much for being such a kind, man. Oh, please. And Justin, too. please, please give them my love. I will tell her, for sure.
这真的让我惊呆了。当我告诉母亲这件事时，她哭了一个星期。我是说，真的。所以非常感谢你，你真是个好人。噢，别这么说。还有贾斯汀，也请代我向他们问好。我一定会转达的。
And it's something, and I can't quite remember Jason, but it was a flight from either Los Angeles to London, Pan Am, which doesn't exist, of course, or from London to L.A., I can't remember. And I was just, I was very vulnerable, not because I have a fear of flying, I don't. Something was happening, and for some reason, Victoria, your mom spotted something on me,
那是一件事，杰森，我记不太清了，但那是一次从洛杉矶飞往伦敦的泛美航空航班——当然，这家航空公司已经不存在了——或者是从伦敦飞往洛杉矶，我记不清了。当时我非常脆弱，不是因为我怕坐飞机，我并不怕。当时发生了一些事情，不知为何，维多利亚，你妈妈在我身上察觉到了什么，
and she just took care of me. Yeah. She'd bring me tea and check on me every so often. And I'll just never forget it. You know, and I was... She was... Look at both these guys. Very special.
她只是照顾我。是的。她会给我端茶，时不时来看看我。我永远不会忘记这一点。你知道，我当时……她是……看看这两个家伙。非常特别。
Just writing jokes. As soon as you said, take care of me, both of them wrote about six jokes. Well, luckily he followed it up and said with a cup of tea. With a cup of tea. They put their pens down. I didn't need to, yeah. She was very accommodating.
就在写笑话。你一说照顾我，他们俩就写了大约六个笑话。好吧，幸运的是他接着说，端了一杯茶。端了一杯茶。他们放下了笔。我不需要，是的。她非常乐于助人。
Well, that's very sweet. It's so great. And again, Liam, such a fan. And thank you so much. Yeah, it was such a good of you. I was an honor to talk with the three of you. Thank you so much. Can you say hi to Laura if you talk to her before I do?
嗯，那太贴心了。真是太棒了。再次感谢，利亚姆，真是个大粉丝。非常感谢你。是的，你真是太好了。能和你们三位交谈是我的荣幸。非常感谢。如果你在见到劳拉之前和她说话，能帮我向她问好吗？
I sure will. I love her so much. She's going over to Ireland, I think, in May to shoot a film. I'm going over there to shoot a film at my best dear friend, Karen Hines. Oh, yeah. We're going to shoot a film and Donnie Goal. You're not killing anybody in that, are you? Oh, yeah.
我一定会。我非常爱她。我想她五月份要去爱尔兰拍电影。我要去那里和我最亲爱的朋友凯伦·海恩斯拍一部电影。哦，是的。我们要去多尼戈尔拍一部电影。你不会在里面杀人吧？哦，是的。
You are? Yeah, of course. Quite a few. Quite a few. Yes. Why do you think he took the part? Is the Pope were Catholic? Come on.
你会吗？是的，当然。杀了不少。杀了不少。是的。你以为他为什么接这个角色？教皇是天主教徒吗？得了吧。
The great Liam Neeson, thank you so much, our friend. Thanks, guys. So nice of you to do this. Thank you, Liam. That's great, thanks, boys. Sure, take care. Bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye. See you later.
伟大的利亚姆·尼森，非常感谢你，我们的朋友。谢谢，伙计们。你们能这样做真是太好了。谢谢你，利亚姆。太棒了，谢谢，伙计们。好的，保重。再见，再见，再见，再见，再见，再见，再见。回头见。
The great Liam Neeson. When he came on the screen, I was like, what? That's so, what? Liam Neeson. I know. He's so, like, iconic. It's so crazy. When I was like, I wanted to have him on the show,
伟大的利亚姆·尼森。当他出现在屏幕上时，我当时想，什么？这太，什么？利亚姆·尼森。我知道。他太标志性了。太疯狂了。当我想，我想让他上节目时，
and then they said, and Michael, MGT, said, yeah, we're going to have Liam Neeson. he's going to do it. I thought like, is this really going to happen? That's crazy. Yeah, how'd you do that, Willie? I don't know.
然后他们说，迈克尔，MGT说，是的，我们要请利亚姆·尼森。他会来的。我当时想，这真的会发生吗？太疯狂了。是的，威利，你是怎么做到的？我不知道。
I have no idea. I think that he thought, you know, I mean, he knew you a little bit and he was such a fan. He talked about seeing us at the garden another time and he wanted to come say hi, and he did not. And his new movie,
我不知道。我想他觉得，你知道，我的意思是，他认识你一点，而且他是你的忠实粉丝。他谈到在花园见过我们，他想来打个招呼，但他没有。还有他的新电影，
memory, comes out April 29th, which is, the guy, God, he's made a round of him. I didn't even get a chance to ask him about Star Wars. Oh, my God.
《记忆》将于4月29日上映，天哪，他真是个大忙人。我甚至没机会问他关于《星球大战》的事。哦，天哪。
Oh, Sean. Too bad. There's not enough Star Wars in the world, I know. Thank God. It's such a shame that we never had an opportunity to talk about fucking Star Wars. He was in so many Star Wars movies. And then he was one of those Stormtroopers in Force Awakens. And you spent your time with Wrath of the Titans, the sequel to Clash of the Titans.
哦，肖恩。太可惜了。世界上《星球大战》还不够多，我知道。谢天谢地。我们没机会谈论该死的《星球大战》，真是太遗憾了。他演过那么多《星球大战》电影。然后他还是《原力觉醒》里的那些冲锋队员之一。而你把时间花在了《诸神之怒》，也就是《诸神之战》的续集上。
That's right. You're going to lose your card. I swear to God. I love it. I really, out of deference to you, I wanted to start it off by asking about theater stories. because he started in the theater. I know, I love that. Thank you, yeah, I love that.
没错。你会丢掉你的会员卡的。我发誓。我喜欢它。真的，出于对你的尊重，我想从询问戏剧故事开始。因为他是从戏剧开始的。我知道，我喜欢那个。谢谢，是的，我喜欢那个。
I love, you'd think people would have, like, at the Redis. Well, it turns out, it does start to feel like the only embarrassing things in the theater happened to you. Yeah, and Kristen Chenoweth. And the time that you, poison Christian Jennerner, I forget how the story went, but... Maybe she just had an anxiety attack because the curtain call was such complicated blocking.
我喜欢，你以为人们会，比如，在Redis。好吧，事实证明，这确实开始让人觉得戏剧中唯一尴尬的事情都发生在你身上。是的，还有克里斯汀·肯诺恩斯。还有你，毒害克里斯汀·詹纳的那次，我忘了故事是怎么回事，但是……也许她只是因为谢幕的走位太复杂而焦虑发作了。
So, let's go back. So you came from either side of the... So it was sort of like a buy entrance? Was it a buy entrance? Oh, a what? A buy entrance. Wait, wait, wait. Are we done? Bye.
所以，让我们回到正题。所以你是从……的两侧进来的？所以这就像是一个双向入口？是双向入口吗？哦，什么？双向入口。等等，等等。我们结束了吗？再见。
Bye. I don't endorse it. Smartless. Smart. Smartless. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Rob. JARV, Bennett Barbico, and Michael Grant Terry.
再见。我不支持它。Smartless。聪明。Smartless。Smartless是由罗伯·贾维、本内特·巴比科和迈克尔·格兰特·特里手工制作的100%有机产品。
Smartless. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Smartless。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。